general have you kickoff the first
question what is your shortlist and this
is written from the question was written
for the perspective a project leader but
as a team member short lists of tasks
key tasks that you'd like to accomplish
in your first meeting with with your act
team and most of you will have your
first meeting with your act team today
so we thought this be a highly relevant
question I think it three parts to the
three key tasks to your handbook I put a
little square around team kickoff
meeting which is you know step number 12
or 13 for a project by the time you know
our team kicks off on Biodesign a lot of
things will have happened already there
have been conversations internally
conversations with the client a plan of
a draft plan developed and my first
recommendation would be is get everyone
up to speed on everything that's
happened to date I have been on a
project where it was sort of yeah I
talked to the board member and he said
that's what we wanted and that's what
we're gonna do it's like well it's sort
of like the train has already left the
station and you're running to get on it
so I encourage team leaders to walk
through everything that you know the the
piece of paper that April first got that
the client sent in to every conversation
that's happened and an org chart would
be great here's who I've talked to at
the organization here's what their
position is here's what they said our by
a design team even has a better way of
doing this
Dave blow plow plow is leading it the
clients coming to our first kickoff
meeting he's going to be there for 30
minutes talking about the organization
why there's a project at all and then
he's leaving and then we're having our
meeting hmm so getting everyone up to
speed is the the first thing I'd
recommend at the tail of the meeting I
think is also sort of an easy thing to
that's that's pretty easy to understand
the tail of the meeting is also pretty
easy to understand and I'll talk about
the middle last the tail is sort of what
we all did at NBA school which is you
know okay there's a team there's it you
know there's a sub team there's a sub
team there's a sub team ideally it's two
on a sub team or
three so that if one drops off you still
have someone and there's also pairing of
someone who's really skilled in that
area and someone who's learning a
particular thing that they might not
know as much about one small point on
this one I'm sort of a data walk on
teams is that I like there to be sort of
a data plan in place and talked about at
the early days because it's often the
hardest thing to get one project that I
was on for the YMCA we wanted payroll
data I didn't come until you know four
weeks before the end of the project and
we finally had something to say oh this
is okay now you know now we know that
your turnover rates aren't too hot so I
think that's generally true in
consulting as the data takes awhile so I
left that's the front in the back the
middle is I think it would be helpful
for team leaders to walk through the the
work plan and talk about well let me
back up the I I would want to know as a
joining the team meters sort of take me
through all the elements of the
organization that you know about what's
the mission what are they trying to do
how are they financed whatever the team
leader thought about in advance and
coming up with the work plan what the
client asked for clearly and then to go
through here's what my thinking is on
the work plan and why you know I think
it's this kind of problem this is a
funding problem or for Biodesign you
know I'll give two examples for
Biodesign what I have read and I've only
read the summary and the the what was
marketed to volunteers is that they've
sort of accomplished their mission and
they're looking for what to do next well
that could mean either they don't know
what to do next or they don't know where
the money's gonna come to you for what
they're gonna do next or there's no
demand in the university for what's what
they're doing or it could mean a lot of
different things and I'd want the team
leader to explain exactly sort of the
underlying reason that we're working on
that thing that's the beginning middle
end I would just add that I think it's
worthwhile very early in your effort to
sit down and spend time together
understanding what you
no collectively in what you don't know
because you have an academic expertise
may have been your concentration of
coursework you have the expertise that
you have and what you do for a living
but then there's a whole nother thing
which is like real world experience
which turns out to be pretty valuable
and unless you understand where your
holes are as well as where your
strengths are you may do placate efforts
or end up not having expertise that you
need in a project something that can't
have just three tasks you have to have
six but so something that's easy to do
in the last few minutes of the team
meeting and it's reusable is to set up
an infrastructure which is how are you
going to communicate are you going to
meet it's very basic stuff but it's kind
of what helps you keep the project going
smoothly in terms of this is our mode of
communication we're going to do we're
gonna meet on a weekly basis or not just
things like that it's very simple but
it's nice to get that done so you know
we're all you are one thing I like to do
with my teams is to go through and kind
of find out a little bit about why
everybody actually volunteered and what
their expectations are for the project
so in addition to trying to meet the
clients expectations you know we
certainly try to meet our volunteers
expectations too and there may be things
that might surprise you people may
volunteer because they want to learn
about a certain area or they're trying
to make a career change or or what have
you and it's nice to know that so you
can give your team members those
opportunities as they come up and not
just rely on the people who actually
have the expertise already